If you have pets, you may have wondered whether they know what you're thinking.
Let me share with you what usually happens to me.
My cat hides somewhere when I start planning a trip to the vet.
My dog runs in circles when I think about going out to play.
Both of these events can have logical explanations.
My cat might have heard me pull the carrier off the shelf.
My dog must have seen me glance at his favorite ball.
Well, let me fill you in on an interesting theory.
I work for a pet psychic, also known as an animal communicator,...
...and he would explain these events a little differently.
According to most pet psychics,...
...you communicate with your pets telepathically all the time, without even knowing it.
Your cat hides and your dog gets ready to play...
...because of signals you send with your mind, not because of your actions.
According to pet psychics, electromagnetic energy surrounds and penetrates everything in the universe,...
...much like the "Force" in "Star Wars".
This energy is part of the radio spectrum,...
...but scientists haven't figured out how to detect it.
Pet psychics can use energy to contact animals,...
...no matter how far away the animals are...
...or whether they are still living or not.